just how insane are liberal bail reform
laws criminals think they can get away
with literally anything just take what
happened in New York City a pair of
crooks going on the crime spree of the
century holding 13 people up at gunpoint
and six different robberies during a
wild two-hour Blitz before crashing
their Minivan and getting arrested one
of the suspects bragging the reporters
that they'd be out in bail in no time
out
could have been right it's usually up to
a New York judge to decide if he makes
bail but the feds swooped in and they're
going to prosecute these guys and it's
only been a few years of bail reform
insanity but it looks like liberals want
to make some changes
I reaffirmed my belief in the necessity
of making changes
and will not turn our backs on the
progress that was made so let's just
simply provide clarity
let's ensure judges consider factors for
serious offenders
and let's leave the law where it is for
low-level offenses
we move forward and focus on to our
other Public Safety challenges
so that
perp bragging to the camera's judge
about being out on bail in 24. do you
think that is what it's finally going to
take to wake these people up no because
no they're still insisting that the New
York Dems say the gaps in the crime data
is the reason bail reform won't change
so what I did was I got the crime data I
mean this I was a D.A so I had the
division of Criminal Justice Services
they come out with this crime data every
year now either they're stupid or they
need eyeglasses because it's very clear
here that in 2020 and 2021 40 of those
who were released under supervision
reoffend you see that rearrest 40
percent and the nonsense the people who
like don't believe Your Lying Eyes who
believe in that concept are saying these
are troubling gaps that make it
difficult to get an accurate picture
that's nonsense this is an accurate
picture and you know what forget your
division of Criminal Justice Services if
you don't want to believe them listen to
the criminals they know they're getting
out and they're reoffending brother
thank God the U.S attorneys came in and
hit the sky with federal charges are
they going to have to do that more
I'm not exactly sure are you what the
federal charges should be yeah the
question is jurisdiction because crime
is a state matter if they hit him with
something it's got to be a good then do
that right it couldn't even be a gun
it'd have to be like a special nah they
could do a gun anyway that guy if I was
his lawyer I'd go what a schmuck look
what he did he he by daring the system
by by being so Cavalier and so Brazen
and say I'm going to be out in 10
minutes he doomed himself to the most
severe
treatment possible under the law he is
going to get reamed as soon as uh uh you
know the cameras are off him
um bail reform is a failure at the the
association of district attorney said it
has been extremely detrimental to Public
Safety I understand some of the
politicians are saying gaps in data
baloney use your common sense if someone
is attempting murder if someone is so
threatening that they are you know
getting into your space getting into
your homes threatening your families
these people should and dangerousness
must be considered by the judge in
setting bail it's a it's a function not
just of what you did but what they think
you're going to do to the same victim or
if it's a husband who beats up the wife
and you say okay it's domestic violence
that's quite so serious maybe we'll uh
give them bail for fifty dollars or five
hundred dollars baloney then he goes and
kills the wife when he's you know as
soon as he gets out on bail it's it's it
is something we must reconsider bail
exists for two reasons one is to make
sure you show up at trial that is true
the other one must be the protection of
Public Safety and public welfare and not
only did he taunt the politicians Dana
it looks like he's calculating what the
risks are before holding up a half a
dozen people they are that that's
because they know that's the other thing
is is that they've changed the law here
for juvenile offenders so they raise the
age so now let's say you are 16 and you
commit a violent crime it goes to
juvenile court Family Court basically
and all those records are sealed and if
you are a violent offender at that time
you don't and you re you recommit a
crime I don't know judge maybe you know
a little bit more about this with me and
obviously I'm maybe getting it wrong
judged on based on your reactions
they raise the age and the problem is
now older people that are in gangs are
using younger people to commit crimes
that are then not being prosecuted the
law and to the point of them taunting
people where in the world is a
Congressional Delegation of New York
where are they they they never comment
for anything about victims or crime or
anything they love to talk about green
energy and the tunnel and all the
infrastructure but they will never
take on this issue but Senator
gillibrand might have to she's up for
reelection in 2024 uh and Lee zeldin
might challenge her and if that's the
case if that's the case that we will
have this conversation again and
people's eyes had been open this last
election and maybe it would be
successful this time all right Gutfeld
you know what's amazing about this story
you can mug for as many people as you
want but don't talk to politicians
that's the limit they've had enough of
you because you made fun of us you made
us look like fools so that's it's about
the words again and not the Deeds we are
truly approaching the Batman world of
Gotham right where the villains find
their arrests and opportunity for
theater it's like whatever the penguin
got arrested or the Joker got arrested
it was like laughing hysterically that's
kind of where we are now because they
know the law so they become Brazen they
become bold uh they're right out of
comic books and Dirty Harry but imagine
I mean remember that I was thinking
about that that guy uh that Bodega
worker that killed that that guy that
tried to stab him how much you want to
bet if somebody had actually responded
to during one of these six muggings and
killed one of these guys how fast would
Alvin Bragg condemn that would they
throw the book at him like they did to
the bodega guy it took it took a
Groundswell of media in public to get to
realize boy we're on the wrong side of
this as they are on the wrong side of
about of this uh bail problem but if
they don't if they don't reverse this
this Good and Evil
fun house mirror that's all you're going
to have left people arming themselves
you're sitting at a they were sitting at
a restaurant outside when this happened
when the when they came and also they
were driving a minivan and you can't get
a getaway car as a minivan you know what
that's a felony I think you're better
Biden was upset that it wasn't an e an
e-band oh maybe next time maybe once
he's out on bail it'll be an evening I
went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now